history ting so this title card informs
me about the real king Arthur and this
is the mid-2000s so I'm positive this is
going to be a gritty ass reboot damn it
just ride proudly the smoke machines
will help and that will cut to a static
map to illustrate your wor dominance my
300 ad Jesus movie are you still
narrating why didn't have to read all
that bullsh
early on if you were gonna then narrate
for five minutes absolute listen to King
Arthur story how much text on screen and
narration based backstory do we need the
only summation soldiers left alive were
members of the decimated but legendary
cavalry these Warriors were incorporated
into the Roman military better they had
died that day god I agree with a
narration here because if they had died
we'd be spared this boring movie of all
the way is to let me know this child
character our horse was Lancelot having
a little girl run screaming his name is
not high on the list of things I would
have chosen why not just have his
knowing father who is already imparting
wisdom also dropped the name or wait
until he's older after I've already
grown to like the character also this
King Arthur movie starts off with of
course a Lancelot origin story don't be
afraid I will return
Lancelot cribs from Jesus in his
farewell speech and of these poor
bastards are poor and all but why the
hell did they decide to settle their
community here there are no crops around
no cattle in sight and then there at the
bottom of an unprotected valley no one
do they have to give all their romans
our post was Britain or at least the
southern half I don't know about you
motherfuckers but I definitely started
watching this Arthurian tale to get some
of that sweet sweet geographical
exposition but the land was divided by a
73-mile wall built three centuries
before us and yet Rome expected Mexico
to pay for it we made our way and
reported to our Roman commander in
Britain Artorius or Arthur the sentence
alone annoys me enough to go ahead and
give this movie its roll credits in
right here now mom does the classic
briefly distract yourself while I
teleport myself several yards away trick
that's helpful anytime your kid needs
help on homework if you so choose they
may someday be used to lead just as your
father before you wait if you so choose
he's already locked in by rule the Roman
edict that he's going to lead these
assholes so not much of a choice there
has always fallen to a few to sacrifice
with a good of many and he totally
butchered that Rafic unquote the world
is
perfect please but perhaps people like
you can make it so okay good talk now
get out of here and Arthur discount ser
loras looks at and before you waste as
much time do Glee as I did know that
it's not the actor who plays sir loss on
Game of Thrones despite his identical
miss weird bro movies less than seven
minutes in it has already exceeded at
swooping shots of English Hills budget
well along was that horse ride you're
telling me this movie's one hundred and
forty minutes but couldn't spend a
little time showing Arthur taking
command of his knights and training them
for fifteen years this is almost as bad
as the Gospels fast-forwarding Jesus
life 230 almost okay so first off this
arrow was shot from an impossible angle
since the woods that the woods are
hiding in is off to the side which means
the archer is definitely not Lee Harvey
Oswald second no one sees this arrow
flying straight at the guard until he's
dead
third light of the woods used the
element of surprise to kill this one
King got they have this impressive aim
why not take out at least four or five
of these guys one of these dickheads
trying to accomplish here
besides finally giving us an action set
piece this is a fucking convoy going
eventually to Rome with a well known
cavalry near behind within eyesight also
this movie totally stole more Braveheart
than I originally thought it did it's
basically King Arthur William Wallace
organs dying arrows from the trees this
Robin Hood Jesus is king Arthur movie
can't figure out which previous movie
wants to rip off the most high though
and looks like he just spent a boatload
of money at the Renaissance Faire then
tied his bedsheet around his neck for
good measure Dan how far away were they
when they started charging if it takes
this long how did they even see the
Romans under attack - premature
celebration look it may surprise you but
I've never been in a medieval battle
having said that this seems like the
worst way to medieval battle I am right
in the sciatic nerve he'll live but he's
definitely going to need one of those
ergonomic desk chairs later in life
I just like to point out that I have no
idea what they're fighting about this is
brutal and a bit over edited but kind of
cool but I just can't connect to brutal
deaths when I have no contact
luckily the first in these warriors
attacked one of the time allowing him to
dispatch them with a Chinese sword that
he knows how to perfectly use even
though he lives in southern England how
did the arrow even get through the wood
earlier they were barely scratching it
he's northern warrior but holes
definitely have some impossible arrows
that's why God descended really just as
a damn movie color-correct much look at
that cool uh shots we do Greengrass
Bishop Jim honest I see your ministry
skills are still have years to you and
why would a bishop have military skills
movie doesn't give a fuck about your
questions please them he's called Murli
a dark magician some say Merlin is
leading England's native army say no
King King Arthur story this is some fan
fiction book rewriting a fake history by
being a nice life longer than the other
well they'll have so Gawain's really
just jerking his own chain for some
extra screen time here also next to this
one horse riding beautiful sound nice
and women beautiful Sarmatian woman why
do you think we left in the first place
hmm at some aces so Tristan is a
world-class archer and expert with a
Chinese sword and an accomplished
falconer Jesus I thought the only thing
interesting about this character was
that he fell in love with Sophia Myles
also moody has to combine several nights
abilities to provide us with the
exceptional weirder that can do anything
cliche and that's been used in any
ensemble action movie ever
I want a sloth alone I've had enough
okay I can buy that Arthur's battle
weary and all that but according to this
movies in his mid-20s and there can have
been that much fighting considering they
would have been training until they were
at least in their late teens this seems
like movies trying to cram in some I'm
too old for the dialogue even though
King Arthur's not played by Danny Glover
also distinct Arthur story has Arthur
and Lancelot already buddies in the
Roman army with Arthur tired of war even
though England's army commanded by
Merlin threatens my point is why the did
you even call this a king Arthur story
why do you think
boar's is understandably happy to see
his wife but how did she not know where
he'd been not like they were out hitting
whorehouses they were heading to get
discharged around table sort of ominous
like it's not like there were no other
round tables and all the roman empire
right it's peculiar for a group of
knights i guess but this overreaction is
both also they already have the round
table area is this a screenwriter
fucking hates the King Arthur legend I
can tell you that so you'll just leave
the land to the world I risked my life
for nothing
well no you were working to gain your
freedom and you were hoping the Romans
would get the fuck out of there one day
so even though there's an invading horde
of Saxons and loads this ultimately
works in your favor dude gentlemen your
discharge papers hang on there are only
six papers here but there are seven
Knights including Arthur even though
he's the commander he's also getting
discharged so that you are to travel
north to ask to the family of Mario
scenarios in particular with Mario son
Alecto you know I love best about
Arthurian legend remembering not only
the regular names of characters but also
the Roman versions I like though is the
Pope's favourite God's child and people
well the hell is he doing in northern
Britain then will you defy the Pope
father Rome God seems have since you
said you're abandoning his homeland of
Britain I'm guessing yes he will defy
heart thereby creating enough conflict
to create a movie you will go on to call
King Arthur even though there's little
resemblance to the Lord fulfill this
mission and your man may we see their
discharge medieval Expendables fat
Knights brothers and arms Arthur's real
legendary ability is his epic bus killed
we must leave on a final mission for
Rome before our freedom can be granted
banner brothers must do one last job
before retiring cliche ideal is talked
of God and not to me well in theory and
I'm just spitballing here but God is a
deity able to control events on earth
whereas you are in theory just a soldier
with the possible crush on Arthur how
many times in battle if we snatch
victory from the jaws of defeat
great question can we see those times
instead of watching 30 minutes of
backstory on the expansion of the Roman
Empire if it being this one burn me and
cost my ashes to a strong east wind
cream a shadowy these job is it to light
all the candles in this basement room so
important people can have important
conversations and how much does that guy
I hate his life the two difference
between this and Game of Thrones is how
obviously everything
these walking dudes is CGI in the shot
in Game of Thrones I can never tell this
at any time you see til Schweiger in a
movie you know they're so evil bit about
to go down if you see til Schweiger with
a shaved head a fur coat and a braided
goatee and we're gonna get into next
level also someone snuck their Captain
America shield on set all the time oh
yeah
movie goes way overboard trying to
convince me the Saxons have the same
kind of infighting Arthur's curves I
know this is the central conflict of the
movie so the Knights have to go alone
but if the mission were so important to
the Pope why wouldn't he at least send
some Roman soldiers to help Arthur out
while this silhouette shot horse riding
looks cool just remember those are all
some people paid a fraction of the
salary of the actors they're pretending
to be right now why should I trust you
traded to your own people he is don't
think I've seen him before
and if I have seen him before it's on
this movie for having so many damn black
haired soldier guys a very high-ranking
family lived there they're of great
importance to Rome but German has
already knew they were going to be
abducted which was the whole reason for
this mission Marius and his brood is
just hanging out in the great wall
waiting to be invaded by the Saxons whoa
that's ragging us what everywhere
Arthur brilliant military tactician that
he is had no idea that the people whose
forests he's invading were tracking him
unfortunately for Arthur his army
happens upon the roads just as they were
putting together a kick-ass new gods eye
craft the section three warriors are
shooting arrows with long barbed wire
attachments which seems at least 300
years ahead of its time as a concept and
an actuality I guess director Antoine
Fuqua like the random you helped me
earlier in the movie so I won't kill you
ex machina he used in training days so
much he wanted to drop that baby out one
more time why would they not attack
Merlin doesn't want instead he just
wants to scare us real bad you see hang
on
an extremely important family to the
Pope is living in hostile territory
lightly guarded by Romans and they keep
the door to the front wall why the
kppen is the club actually trying to
get this kid killed are you from home
from hell damn dude cold mountain wasn't
that bad
I know Excalibur is a fatass sword and
everything but we see nothing in this
movie that indicates it's magical but
Arthur cuts this loose from his iron
chains in one swipe those of you who are
able to gather your things and begin to
move south towards Hadrian's Wall those
unable shall come with us this entire
mission was about getting in and out
with the Pope friendly family Arthur
sees a village and now they're gonna
drag some pools along there are villages
like this everywhere well I know
Arthur's noble wants to take care of
people but he hasn't given a flying
about the pole where this entire movie
yeah I'm glad they included my favorite
Arthur detail snow they have slender's
disease that come from the South trying
to cut up I'll escape they'll be here
before nightfall in addition to his
Falcon intolerance Kristen also has the
ability of teleportation considering
he's mapped out the entirety of the
saxons directional convergence Omani
entirely hilariously on specific
estimate is hilariously on specific what
is this god damn it
suddenly Arthur goes from being Arthur
to a social justice warrior just because
he saw some poor people pouring and
already told movie slows to a crawl
Tata we have no time the same words were
said to director Antoine Fuqua during
the filming of the scene and we're
similarly ignored and nomine dei patris
omnipotentis but seriously the saxon
toward is right on their heels
I know Arthur wants to save everyone
he's basically saying Q to the rest of
the town while he explores his King
dungeon is haughty I guess so much we're
getting everyone to safety you must not
say to me look you rescue an imprisoned
kid and then you tell them this all
while being a super huge intimidating
fellow what gives oh man they left a
perfectly good Keira Knightley down here
his arm is broken and she's family
strangely enough they're doing quite
well she's a won't wanna beer is a word
which is loosely translated as
complicated love interest who shows up
halfway through the dope a few still do
the task
god I sat for that moving on a few sorry
you're soft we interrupt the scripting
Arthurian tail to bring you in study of
medieval who can do hmm well sorry
mmm we interrupt this gripping our three
hmm dammit sorry hmm wiener up this cock
his roams high support up corsets King
Arthur's once he saw Quinn of ear and
his woad started growing that was wrong
right I know everybody on this island
has a road on the side some of your
fingers are not took place I have to
push them back at least two of the
highly-trained Knights that should be
keeping watch for the incoming Saxons
are on this wagon playing doctor someone
who goes by the name of a furious it's
odd one of the many strengths of the
Saxon people is their ability to solve
complex riddles like this
thanks for the carriage riders POV movie
that utterly hates me Anthony had the
same avian CGI budget as Birdemic this
is heaven for me I don't believe in him
Jesus Christ at this point I'm rooting
for til Schweiger or stone skarsgrd or
the bishop or anybody who actually does
something this movie
kake's is a nice sponge bath to wash all
that Bale Britishness off your face
Arthur's mom clearly attended the
Prometheus school of backing away from
things yeah because the whole Lady of
the lake or sword in the stone myths
were sooo lame let's have Arthur yank
Excalibur out of his dead father's great
did you know your hands seemed to be
better everyone is extremely casual
about whenever you're killing one of the
people the Pope specifically has to be
saved I mean even if Arthur succeeds
gets back to Rome he pissed off the Pope
what my father be so wrong baby well the
Summoner brought three slaves no that
isn't true that's the entire premise of
the Knights backstory didn't Arthur
listen to the narration at the beginning
of his own cooking movie why are they
walking so slowly on the ice I mean
they're out there on a frozen lake so
it's a crack there anyway might as well
scoot along with some urgency
right even when this movie should be
actioning it's more interested in people
shouting dialogue
hahaha combat make sure to stretch first
it's been a long time since we've done
anything in this movie hey
saxon archers have we've been taught how
to aim by the needle stormtroopers so
the ice just stopped breaking them it
was a brief bout of excitement now we're
back to contemplative stairs battle is
an extremely obvious metaphor for this
movie lily has no time to show what the
Saxons did after the ice brook blood has
a spare 20 seconds for wide-angle
equestrian born you know the rescue
mission really wasn't that bad
if they hadn't picked up all those
strangers Arthur his knights and Mary's
his family would have made it back to
the wall easily and even with the
strangers they only lost one night after
heroic suicidal gesture so what was
everyone bitching about before his arm
is broken okay so his broken arm is
magically healed after a long journey
and bitter cold with no treatment
available goodbye old friend don't feel
too bad at least Dagenais doesn't have
to make it through the rest of this
movie which has almost a whole thing
hour left what are you afraid of father
I don't know but it's definitely not
long pauses and sweeping shots of
horseback riding look one of your is a
load right one of the sworn enemies of
the Roman army but she's allowed to walk
around the skill room in compound with
impunity thankfully the Saxons waited
for Arthur to properly apply his
guyliner before attacking Oh
medieval see you also come on
why do we need a han solo moment for all
the remaining Knights you're saying one
of these goes but just stick around and
fight even I had it yeah remember that
super dangerous what army we were
supposed
be worried about the first quarter of
this movie but there was that one scene
where Merlin was like we're cool now
that the Romans are gone and then keira
knightley almost d'Arthur so they're not
dangerous anymore except against the
evil stellan skarsgrd army thank god
they're here Antoine Fuqua prefers his
Guinevere as a bloodthirsty painted Lilu
like savage and a leather bikini top
that's somehow it's an arm battalion
thank you very much
even stellan skarsgrd looks like he's
bored with his movie and that dude
white-knuckled it through deep musik are
you fighting cock I fight for a cause be
on drums or your understanding and I'm
still trying to figure it out myself
since one of you told me yesterday that
I should be fighting for Britain or
something and she's really hot doesn't
matter for battle but they're standing
right there on lined up and they're not
already prepared movie it takes the
goddamn horses to convince these
assholes to return and help Arthur oh
yeah I totally forgot about Hugh Dancy
this role is so small he should just be
called sir not appearing in this bill
[Music]
like I think the gate
rather than gain very important
first-hand information from his own
soldier let's put that car down for
having the balls to spout hyperbole I
wish I had any clue where we are on this
battlefield or how the battle is going
there what relation going to be areas to
Arthur and the knights or who this
random beardo is it's going to die a
horrible death important characters lock
eyes and ready for one-on-one fighting
as the battle rages around them cliche
also why are we supposed to care here
sir decant Kristen had never even met
before so this sequence only exists to
build some suspense before Tristan
inevitably dies and gets Arthur even
more of a rage Connor
I guess these two have a history that
raises the stakes here you know because
they looked at each other for that one
second during the ice thing where nobody
really did anything
Lancel ex machina and merlin hasn't done
the whole battle can he shoot an arrow
or pick up a sword or magic something
damn what stars are doing with dude's
head I guess that rage boner had to be
dealt with all Britons will be united in
one common cause to consistently what's
got one
[Music]
and the men's up here but watch a lot
but I thought are they all three down
there they'll quit routines and all the
scenes of a fucking back cable so men
are to the Knights of legend
perhaps so we'll survive if it is God's
will that's it
what we some kind of Suicide Squad lines
my heartbeats I rule I rule
uh-huh
I'm Ripley it's nice to meet you
what is it your period okay suppose
Danica says America mesmerist Aziz the
day may come when the courage of men
fails when it is not this day